I am super excited to be following another
history talk it's really relevant to hear
where we came from so we know where we're
going. Like Lindsay said my name is Whitney
I am a front-end developer from Greenville
South Carolina. Two of my favourite things
are JavaScript and Germany, speaking on stage
here is like the best thing ever.
If you have any questions, you can tweet at
me on Twitter I am also in German if you have
questions you can ask me in the hallway or
on Twitter in German. Fortunately this talk
is in English. So, this talk is about ideas
and not aesthetics. For many people it was
associated with a particular style and has
a particular look. While it's true the Bauhaus
left behind a distinct visual legacy the school
and its makers left behind something that’s
way more important than the visual style.
That's a way of thinking. So for this talk
we'll focus a lot more on the visual or a
lot less on the visual, a lot more on the
methodology and the reason behind it. In other
words we're going to focus a lot more on the
what, and a lot more on the why less on the
what. So because the visual legacy is also
important I have tried to include a lot of
that stuff the pictures in my talk, but hopefully
you will get a picture of the idea that it's
more than just this sort of look.
So the industrialisation of the 19th century
end of World War I and the dissolution of
the German monarchy brought about social political
changes without with the Bauhaus would have
been pretty much inconceivable. It came about
at a time when everything was changing, and
Germany was really undergoing a revolution
not just in design but in the entire country.
It's something I think is really, really interesting.
At this time factories for the first time
were really starting to mass distribute stuff
inexpensively in the mid-1880s but most of
the stuff that was designed and produced was
of incredibly awful quality. It was that sort
of throwaway produce where it was good for
a little while then all of a sudden once it
broke there was no fixing it, you threw it
out. Arts & Craft movement came along said
we want to switch and make something that’s
beautiful, amazing, something the complete
opposite of mass produced. So in the 1860s
they started to try to reconcile decoration
with design so this idea that stuff had a
lot of detail, and a lot of really beautiful
surface sort of stuff on top of it. This was
something that factory made goods beforehand
just plain old didn't have, and could not
reproduce.
So the Bauhaus was formed from a merger of
Saxony's Kunstschule and the Kunstgewerbeschule.
I say those in German there are no words for
them in English. It basically means arts school,
the technical title was Staatliches Bauhaus
Weimar, they sought to work within the limitation
of less expensive materials and really produce
something that was of really, really nice
quality and it was also well designed so they
hoped to bring these two ideas together and
say we can make something that is beautiful
and it's functional but it's also affordable
to the everyday person.
The other thing that Gropius really tried
to do was that he tried to build and shape
a new kind of designer in a human being, he
thought could change the world really.
A big question I am going to ask today is
how did the Bauhaus ideas and approaches stand
the test of time, how are they still relevant
today, almost 80 years later. So this school’s
founder Walter Gropius like I said he hoped
to create this new designer, this new human
being that could change the world. Less than
four years after its founding his school was
internationally known and had become a meeting
place for the European avant-garde in an industry
that’s changing and seeking the next big
thing. I want to look at how almost hundred
years later the Bauhaus in this style and
idea of how we design and how we write our
JavaScript, has sort of experience of resurgence
in popularity. So to shape the new designer
envisioned by Walter Gropius, education at
the Bauhaus was not just limited to academic
knowledge but they really encouraged experimentation,
collaborative learning in the idea of friendly
interaction between the masters an students,
so you had a lot of good stuff like Bauhaus
parties that were legendary. They had the
white party, the yellow party, the red party
and I went and visited Bauhaus and you see
the architecture if you see the sort of atmosphere
that they believed it's incredible how everything
that came into not just a school and learning
and ok sitting in a classroom but really a
lifestyle. It was incredibly interesting how
they did it, and did it very differently.
Unfortunately, I think a hundred years later
our industry has lost its way, unlike the
Bauhaus where they try to create this collaborative
movement and lifestyle, we have really gone
off the rails and far from cultivating friendly
interaction we really are struggling as a
community to build a welcoming, cohesive community.
Instead a lot of the time we're building up
barriers that are not just senseless but they
stand in the way of real progress. We tend
to sort of surround ourselves with people
who think like us, they look like us, they
talk like us, we end up seeking out inspiration
within our tiny circle - that's a huge mistake.
One of the most, I guess important for me,
personal sort of struggles in the JavaScript
community is this which is the ridiculous
split between designers and developers. It's
really, really harmful, thinking we can do
stuff together so rather than collaborate
so rather than collaborating to
achieve common goals, designers and developers
I think a lot of times really feel like hey
we're on competing teams, we're fighting against
each other and we can't come together and
say hey, you know what at end of the day all
we want to do is ship a product, and that
goes together, we're all in this together.
This uneasiness, it stands in the way of successful
collaboration. In reality the principles of
good design often mirror those of good development.
So while it can be said that the school and
its masters issued this harmonious atmosphere
that Gropius set forth in his Bauhaus manifesto
back in 1919, instead the Bauhaus was incredibly
progressive for its time and Gropius believed
that through the process of modernisation
he could master that via design and that the
arts and crafts would form the foundation
of all activity, and so he really wanted to
bring everything together sort of under one
umbrella. Unlike the European arts schools
of the time he actually - which typically
taught art and design as 2 totally separate
subjects never together the Bauhaus decided
to bring those 2 together and reverse the
split between art and production which up
until that point really had not been done,
it was either you were a fine artist or a
designer, and never both that's something
that's really, really interesting the idea
that hey we do have roots in fine arts and
craft it's something that’s very important.
So the struggle to reconcile the fine arts
that was happening back then in the early
20th century that really for me mirrors our
development community struggle to reconcile
code with design. A lot of times we sort of
we blame the complexity of modern websites
or apps, we say we really need an increasing
amount of specialisation from today's designers
and developers and we forget that even back
then, there was this huge challenge of physical
architecture and building and similarly we
still face the same kinds of challenges. It's
still difficult.
I think that the way that we fix this, is
to move away from tiny circles, we move away
from picking sides, we move away and we shape
and create a community that we can be proud
of and that's going to be a community where
developers and designers they really work
with each other, instead of against each other.
I think that is the first step for me.
So in the Bauhaus in order to prepare students
that introduced a foundation called Liberate
the People individually from the dead weight
of convention, he really wanted to get away
from all the Old Masters stuff and so the
course, the foundation course the The Vorkurs
was originally taught by Johannes Itten, it
uses eccentric Swiss painter guy his aim was
to form the creative individual so for the
first time instead of looking at the Old Masters
works then just copying them it was like hey
ok let's look at these works and tell a sort
of what is happening here, let's learn form,
let's learn colour, composition, let's learn
all of these things that the masters are teaching
us but instead of copying that work let's
just go ahead an say I am going to take my
inspiration from this but I am going to make
something myself. So I am going to learn by
creating and not by copying.
So, by 1923 Gropius had started to shift his
ideas a little bit. Itten, said he was a bit
of a weird guy, his increasing focus on individual
artistic expression as well as his involvement
in this religious group/cult called the Mazdaznan
religious group, started to irritate Gropius,
went a little bit off the
rails. Gropius desired a more intense collaboration
with technology, he really wanted to make
that the focus, and so it was dismissed and
instead they transferred the leadership of
the Vorkurs to 2 new people, Josef Albers
and Laszlo Moholy-Nagy, integration of designed
technology and industrial production, this
course in the The Vorkurs become one of the
Bauhaus most defining pedagogical features,
it still exists in many design schools today,
it's something that really changed the way
we think about design the way that we teach
design and it's still incredibly relevant.
The other thing that they came up with was
this idea that form follows function, the
quote itself ‘form follows function’ was
actually from an American it's not from the
Bauhaus, which is why I didn't put it in the
slides, but yeah, so this idea that everything
has a purpose.
So after this increasing political and economic
pressure from the conservative parties forced
the Bauhaus out of Weimer, they needed to
find a new location. So in 1925 the school
relocated to Dessau, they have an incredible
museum I would really recommend you all go
to if you are all interested. The one here
in Berlin is unfortunately a) not friendly
and b) not interesting. , so it's
here in Dessau that Gropius founded the new
building so he also built houses for the Bauhaus
teachers essentially to live in, these are
called Meisterhauser. They all interact with
these building significant interest from inside
Germany itself but also from abroad. As industrial
output grows the German population become
a lot more urbanised, they starting living
more cities. They focused on industrial mass
production and technology, for him technology
was incredibly important, he had an almost
singular focus on this. A lot of the time
contemporaries are like we really think this
is a mistake, looking back in retrospective
is this stubborn quality that made the Bauhaus
this revolutionary, this embracing of technology,
this embracing of change saying we know this
is different we don't care, we're going to
do it anyway, we think it’s the right thing
to do.
Similarly the modern web is evolving at a
super, super incredibly fast rate. We either
face this challenge of we're going to adapt
or we're going to be left behind
Listening to a lot of the other talks, that
talk about yes, 2015, it's pretty obvious
if you don't talk about this stuff now you
don't have a career as a JavaScripter, two
years from now, certainly not ten years from
now, that's something we really need to take
into consideration.
So JavaScript developers are seeking to push
the boundaries of the web, developing new
experiences that weren't possible a few years
ago, not even popular or possible a couple
of months back we complain a lot about oh
my God we really have to learn the new frameworks,
learn to build the new features and tools,
we have to look at applications, there is
so much stuff to get through and we complain
a lot. Whoops...
One thing I think that we kind of forget is
that being revolutionary means taking risks,
it means challenging ourselves and saying,
hey, we are ready for this. It's easy to forget
that the challenges we face today are not
linked to us and our culture and our time,
they're actually - they are very different
to the challenges that Gropius faced, but
at the same time they are also incredibly
similar, we are facing the pressure to go
forward, to reinvent ourselves to keep making,
to keep doing, to always sort of churning
out new work, it's exhausting, it was exhausting
back then and it's exhausting now, but it's
something that we just can't get around.
So, the real question then is how do we sort
of avoid burn out, what can we do that's meaningful
and worthwhile? These are problems that are
really hard to solve, because for everyone
it's incredibly different, there is no one
solution that we can fix for everybody, but
what we need to remember is that progress
and not perfection is our goal. You just need
to, we need to try it, we need to keep moving
forward. It's not an end game thing. There
is always going to be something new to learn.
So, Gropius actually, he really failed to
realise the idealistic dreams that he had
in his opening manifesto, but his influence
is still really incredibly strong today, almost
100 years later and the way of thinking that
he left behind is enormously influential not
just in the fields of education and architecture
but also in design and development.
So, umm... like I said, there were three leaders
of the Bauhaus, each of the Bauhaus directors
worked to change and change the world of design
in its section in the world in its own way,
Gropius seeked to close the gap between the
artist and the citizen to bring art to every
burn he wanted to make well designed products
available to the masses. The was Hannes Meyer,
you won't find out about him in the history
books, it's starting to change more, he was
politically unsavoury at the time, eventually
thrown out, interesting his time as Director
of the Bauhaus he tried to bring to the forefront
the social aspect of designs and provide goods
for the people rather than the luxury. The
final Director of the Bauhaus, refers to a
lot of what Meyer said, he was politically
not savoury at the time, umm... so Ludwig
Mies van der Rohe, so he reversed a lot of
the decisions and refocused the school back
to architecture, in particular the connection
between building technology and aesthetics,
the students stood that forefront of the industry
and they believed they could use technology
to make the world better. For them the idea
of acceptability enjoyed a much broader context,
back then it meant just something was accessible
period, available period. Now we sort of have
this period of acceptability being with a
screen or being with a particular device,
that's true now in the modern context, but
really at its core we assume that people have
these devices and these screens, but at the
same time it's really, really important that
we remember that we're not supporting devices,
we're not supporting screens, we're not supporting
things, we are supporting people. I think
that's, that's very different from this idea
of - I'm going to do something that works
on every product, what you really want to
do is build something that is accessible by
every individual person.
So, for Gropius leading the Bauhaus was an
incredibly exhausting and he leaned a lot
on the Masters of form, the teachers at the
Bauhaus, initially this sort of struggle of
keeping the Bauhaus alive especially in
Germany at a time when things were falling
apart all over the place, was incredibly just
awful and it brought them together, originally,
but conflict sort of, it... it builds on itself,
it gets worse. Unfortunately the sort of collaborative
spirit that Gropius tried to build in the
beginning started to fall apart, so it was
exacerbated by the constant shift on teachers,
the politically scene was very radical in
Germany and also very owe pre-sieve, it led
to an erosion of passion and collaborativeness,
people stopped wanting to work together, instead
things fell apart around Gropius and eventually
he left. During his time leading the Bauhaus,
he wanted to create this, you know, hey we're
all in this together. It was probably really
influenced by his time in the organisation
called the Deutsche Werkbund, for the rest
of his career, looking back at the Bauhaus,
thing, "Wow, I tried hard", things really
fell apart, he started to value the I'd of
partnership over individual so he said this
was something that really affected him for
the rest of his career.
So, almost 90 years since the closing of the
Bauhaus we are still confronting the same
exhaustion, the same idea of, we're not as
enthusiastic sometimes as we used to be when
we are building things. Like the Masters,
we struggle to balance our desire for praise,
the idea that we personally built the whole
thing, that we personally tried some new technology,
we struggle to work together to accomplish
something as a team, this frenetic pace of
JavaScript development today makes the situation
worse, we have to master new technology and
support an ever expanding array of devices,
a lot of times it's just exhausting, we feel
overwhelmed, exhausted sometimes both, sometimes
we are faced with the decision to become specialists
or generalists, we can't possibly learn everything,
it's really frustrating. So I think what we
should do is look back at what Gropius did
and say, hey, what we really need to do is
establish a set of guiding principles that
will guide our community. When we look back
and we look at what Gropius achieved, you
know, he really didn't achieve his initial
vision what he set out to do, what he set
out to do isn't in the history books. Even
after the Bauhaus closed the students and
teachers emigrated all around the world and
took the ideas with them.
So where does it leave us, what does this
walk through history show us? Gropius developed
this new technology of mass produce with beauty
and functionality, he said the final goals
of artistic activity is architecture, what
I want to say is that for him buildings, they
represented the coming together of knowledge,
inspiration and he referred to this by a German
word Gesamtkunstwerk, so, what I think is
really cool, is to think that the web is Gesamtkunstwerk,
it's this coming together of all of the things,
it's our product, it's are culture, it's our
industry. We're not likely to leave behind
physical sort of remnant, the architecture
of the buildings like the Bauhaus was, but
80 years from now, 100 years from now, when
they look at us and they say, "What did the
JavaScript developers of 2015 leave behind?"
It's actually our culture, the way we build
things, the way we work with people and not
the actual things that we leave behind, I
want our legacy to be something we are truly
proud of.
If you have questions, I'll answer them in
the hall, obviously in English or also in German